We're going to use
the mean shift algorithm
to find the modes within
that distribution.
By the way, the slides I'm going to
show you, I've showed you before, and
again these are all over the internet.
It says originally from Ukraine.
It's in Sarel, and if that's who did it,
and I thank you for
doing these animations,
because everybody uses them.
So the idea of mean
shift is the following.
Here, I have the distribution
of points in some future space.
I plop down some region of interest.
And that region is
drawn here as a circle,
but think of it as a Gaussian blob,
right?
So, it actually is more weighted in
the middle, than it is to the outside.
Mean-shift tends to work a little bit
better if you have a center waiting.
The reason for that is,
if I've got a hard circle on the end,
then if I move it a little bit, I might
run into a bunch of new points, and
it'll change my value quickly.
And I'd like to things to always be
smooth when I move things around, so
by having a fall-off in the galaxy,
and, as I get there sl,
as I get there, those points have a,
a little bit of influence, and
then they gain more influence.
So what happens is I put down
this region of interest.
I compute the center of mass,
that's the weighted center of mass, and
the difference between them,
that's called my mean shift vector, and
I just shift my mean there.
Isn't that a beautiful animation?
And what do I do?
I do it again.
I compute the weighted center of mass.
There it is.
New Mean Shift vector shift it.
[SOUND] Marvelous.
And what do I do?
I do it one more time, and
I keep doing this until I've converged.
And there are some interesting proofs
of convergence under some reasonable
assumptions and,
that finds you this mode.